devant les pharmacies de kiev des files
d'attentes les ukrainiens font des
provisions
près de deux jours de couvre-feu et ils
peuvent enfin sortir
et sourire à tout
pécheur le bonito cause you like it
should be strong
positive fera it right
un homme n'a pas le temps d'attendre il
donne une liste de médicaments
on est en dehors ils prennent des
risques les sirènes résonnent
régulièrement ils sont presque habitués
certains font des courses pour les
ukrainiens qui ont pris les armes contre
les russes
si les rues de kiev sont quasi désertes
la gare elle est très animé
ils sont des milliers chaque jour a
tenté de quitter kiev par tous les
moyens peur des raids aériens et d'une
possible entrée des troupes russes dans
la capitale ukrainienne certains
prennent le train d'autres la route et
là ça peut être très dangereux avec des
routes endommagées et des combats qui
continuent un peu partout autour de la
capitale avec des chars russes qui sont
à moins de 30 kilomètres de kiev
et ce chiffre qui ne cesse d'augmenter